[MUSIC]
I grew up being
a self-centered kid in school.
Sure, I could do fast math, but I did not
give a shit about others who could not.
I could calculate the cube root of
738 in my ahead when I was just 12.
When my friends struggling
with basic fractions and
decimals asked me for
help, I turned a blind eye.
I hadn't mastered calculus yet,
the National Math Olympiad was around
the corner, and my parents and
teachers had big expectations of me.
I needed to focus on myself, and
my friends would have done the same
thing if they were in my place.
I received straight A's in the math and
sciences but
if there had been a class for
helping people, I would have got an F.
The national education system in India,
like in many parts of the world
is predicated on the idea of relative
performance and competition, and
this dominates our view of success.
I didn't think it was possible to break
out of this belief until I met two
people four years back, Anju and
Xabi, two kids nearly half my age.
Anju just 15 years old lived in a village
that did not send girls to school.
But rather than try to move to a different
village and get her education,
she devoted her energy in changing
the minds of people in our community.
Her determination changed the system, and
she has now had more than 200 girls to
enroll in school and become educated.
Xabi just 16,
convinced his school principal to start
an animal shelter in their school campus.
While he, and his fellow
classmates have rescued more than
300 injured dogs to date.
I was fascinated with Anju and Xabi,
for the first time in my life I met
teenagers who cared deeply about others,
and took action to make things better.
I certainly wasn't like that when I was in
school and neither were the kids I knew.
So, why was that?
Why were Anju and Xabi the outliers and
not the mainstream?
The more I thought about it, it all
pointed to our education systems and
the extreme competitive
pressure that is put on kids.
You got good grades,
great now get better grades.
You made it into a good college,
fine, now get into a better college.
Life becomes this competitive race and
this race engulfs children in
an inward looking me focus mindset
rather than developing an outward
looking we focus mindset.
Children leave schools with impressive
grades and certificates and
get decent jobs, but they miss
becoming empathetic, responsible,
conscious citizens of this world.
But should school systems choose between
academic excellence and empathy and
compassion, I didn't think so and
I chose to do something about it.
I quit my job and started a social
enterprise to try and tackle this issue.
As part of our research, I read a lot
about people who have dedicated their
lives towards the betterment of society,
and how they develop their passion for it.
That's when I was introduced to
Bill Drayton, Bill is credited by many for
coining the term social
entrepreneur back in the 1970s.
Ashoka the nonprofit he founded support
social entrepreneurs in more than 40
countries today.
But what's interesting is this, when Bill
was 11 If he had started an initiative
to help his classmates by
creating a class newspaper.
He skipped a lot of classes because
of his strong commitment and
wasn't even home most evenings.
When his mother died,
he found correspondence between her and
a school principal.
His mother was concerned she asked, why
is a fifth grader not in your school or
at home?
The school principal wrote back saying,
trust your son, and
please don't show you're anxious.
But he was unaware of this at the time,
but when he thinks back on it,
he says bless principle who encouraged my
ability to make an impact in this world.
We found two patterns in the stories
of people like Bill, number one,
most develop their passion for creating
change by going through an outward
centric change making
experience at a very young age.
And number two, they had at
least one adult who believed and
supported them in their journey.
Inspired by these learnings, our team
designed a program for middle school and
high school children.
Our idea was to encourage the kids to
identify social or environmental issues in
their home, school or community,
support them as it took action to try and
tackle these issues and
appreciate them for their efforts.
Our role as facilitators was to do
three simple things, encourage,
support and appreciate, or
what we call the ESA framework in short.
Who could be against such a program,
right?
Yet we couldn't convince a single
school in the first two months.
Schools rejected us outright saying
that they did not see any value and
that children needed to focus
solely on their academics.
We finally offered the entire
program to schools for free for
an entire year to get them to try it out.
Not an ideal start for us but
we took what we could get.
If convincing schools and
parents was tricky, thankfully working
with children was the exact opposite,
children loved our program.
They quickly identified the problems
they wanted to tackle and
passionately got to work.
Chandan just 11 years old told us
I want everyone in my school to be
physically fit.
His school did not offer a physical
fitness program, so he gathered a group of
other sixth graders and started
a student run yoga class for everyone.
Even two years since our program ended,
the children still run their yoga class
and in fact have expanded their
initiative to five nearby schools.
Incredible, Jonathan's teacher
recently told us that Chandan was
an extremely shy kid at first.
But once he got a platform to
solve a problem he cared about,
he discovered a new side of himself,
Chandan is no longer that timid child,
he's an empowered agent of change.
Kielty just 15 started the Code Red
initiative to spread awareness about
menstrual hygiene in underprivileged
communities near her school.
She was so successful that now
three years since her program,
she's helping an NGO create
awareness about cerebral palsy.
Told me in my 10 years of schooling,
I never had an adult who encouraged me
to think about helping my community.
But as soon as I received that
encouragement, my life changed and
now I want to continue tackling meaningful
issues for the rest of my life.
This was common amongst all the students.
After working with more than
25,000 children over three years,
our biggest realization was this.
All children are born with empathy and
compassion, the challenge is to
remain with it as we grow up.
These humane values can either thrive and
flourish with encouragement and
support from adults or they can be
completely stifled and suppressed.
Which is what happens through
our education systems.
Which one do we all want for
our children, for our community?
We have big problems today
political polarization,
growing inequality, climate change,
we must fundamentally change the way
we are raising our children.
We must set them free from this
inward looking me focused mindset,
to an outward looking we focused mindset.
Looking back, I don't believe my career
would have been any less successful if I
had more empathy and
compassion as a child.
But I can't help but
wonder how much better the lives of my
other young friends would have been?
Would their careers be better, would they
have passed the along the empathy they had
experienced onto their own children?
Academicians, researchers and advocates
are fighting to include empathy and
compassion into the formal curriculum
at the institutional level.
And each one of us, you and me, can make
a difference at the individual level.
Implement ESA, encourage the children in
your life to think about and help others.
Support them when they
start something meaningful,
and appreciate them for
when they put in the efforts.
Be their champion,
the one who keeps their empathy alive so
that no matter who they
become professionally or
where they go in the future,
they create a better world for everyone.
Thank you very much.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]